look guys we're going to get through
these we're going to figure out the new
best cr
the best newest christmas song all right
let's try this one i've got a couple
from this guy
songwriter x uh this is a christmas
concert this is a
a spanish christmas no this isn't
kicking it with ben this is an entirely
different person
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i can't tell this guy's a rabbi
a hitman a cowboy
or a businessman on casual friday i
cannot figure it out it seems like he's
everything but also nothing
[Music]
he looks like an amish vampire it's very
funny flawed
[Music]
argentinian computer salesman all right
i'll accept that as well
low rent undertaker angry druid says
[Music]
by the way it's an 11 minute song we're
not gonna play the whole 11 minutes but
we have to get at least the gist of it
a
[Music]
this feels like a five-ish skit
just ripped from the five-ish video
[Music]
also how is this a christmas song
[Music]
all right look sorry man that's a no
again for me
i i just can't he he did another one so
let me give him another
shot all right this is his reggae
christmas
that's right you heard me right this is
the same gentleman this is songwriter x
who i've just subscribed to
this is his reggae christmas
all right all right everything iri
everton iran
[Music]
estimated it's your uncle i'm sorry
somebody told me it was christmas
that we should act like it was christmas
all right
[Music]
that's not mick foley
this looks like a fever dream carnival
at a retirement home
okay i understand the reggae part and i
get that it's christmas
but why is there a skeleton
[Music]
pass
this is by far the worst episode of
firefly i've ever seen
okay look again no i'm gonna say no i
mean if you guys have a different vote
you tell me but i'm going to i'm going
to say no
on this one i just i can't that's this
this doesn't replace
this is not going to replace a mariah
carey christmas song or pretty much any
new christmas song
this is terrible guys you see me putting
in the work all right one more and i
think at this point he's panning to me
this one's called a cuban tropical
christmas
i can't wait to see his take on this
recording
hi guys merry christmas
you know susie says i'm crazy because
that
she's laughing over there behind the
camera oh my god is he cuban
oh no no no no please don't be cuban
please don't be cuban please don't be
cuban
because i've decided we're gonna put out
a christmas
song every day between here and
christmas don't you think that's right
hey 12 days of christmas well actually
it's going to be 13 because today is the
12th
cupid
the last thing we needed was another one
singer
that's the last thing we needed was
another cuban singer
all right we'll play it i think that's
right
so today's song is going to be
navidad it looks like kicking it with
bernardo
now without tropical ah he's so cuban
god
damn it why did he have to be cuban
all right you see song i wrote
it's a cuban song tropical
song i wrote for christmas navidad
tropica
and it's coming here you go guys hit it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so let's bring baby jesus tropical fruit
as that was in the bible
it was uh gold frankincense and
pineapples i'm
look check me on this if you want to but
i'm just going off of memory it's been a
while
but it was gold frankincen it was it was
a gold chain
because it's a cuban guy so it's a gold
sign lasso chain
uh frankenstein's
whatever that is and a pineapple is what
they brought him
i'm almost positive
[Music]
guys look i know what you're thinking we
need a food solo and you're welcome
[Music]
i don't like living like this anymore
how do you think i feel
[Music]
he's giving jesus yucca and malanga
which is a root vegetable you probably
wouldn't know what it is
you know what milanga is right you like
malonga
[Music]
but do you like it boiled or fried see i
like fry i like both
but i prefer fried yucca
finally a christmas song of my people
[Music]
i saw jesus with a celebrating christmas
[Music]
come on this guy's a way better singer
that's not nice
look i'm okay i'm gonna lie to you and
you're gonna say i'm biased because
i'm cuban hey you know what it's a
contender i
have turned around on this gentleman
songwriter x
maybe
maybe i i i'm look hey
hey what do you guys think what do we
think
what are we thinking here
huh
he has a biden song
does he does he really
no no he can't he can't pop oh so he's
songwriter x in the skeleton band that
explains the skeletons
he has a biden oh my god i i just
guys sorry look so whatever we didn't
find a christmas song yeah what is this
hi guys i'm anne and susie tomorrow's
the fourth of july
sorry sorry
that's his wife now we know why he voted
for
okay hold on ah
let me get comfortable here
um yeah hi guys
and susie tomorrow is the fourth of july
it is indeed um you know we have a
fourth of july song every year
i have my dolls up to this year because
all the things that have been happening
with corona and the protest and
everything
but i finally come up with the song i
have it right here
right here here are the lyrics so
tomorrow here are the lyrics
we're gonna have a premiere and you know
what it is what we're gonna do right now
we're gonna endorse joe biden
yes we are the song is called joe is a
good guy
he is a good guy i picked joe yeah i
pick you
me too so really joe's a good guy
he has a good heart he will heal all the
divisions tearing us apart
joe has a plan joe's a good man
he'll do away with the craziness tearing
up the land
okay the craziness like wearing a
[ __ ]
wig and an american flag shirt with your
[ __ ]
with your 500 views on your stupid song
[ __ ] you you fake cuba p you're not real
[ __ ] beat it
[ __ ] beat it beat it joe's a good
guy oh i'm mad oh
i'm mad
this is the song
joe's a good guy he had
a good heart he will heal all the
divisions
tearing us apart joe
has a plan joe understands
he learned all this craziness
tearing up the land i picked up
[Music]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] fake cuba
you piece of [ __ ] oh you
oh oh [ __ ]
pieces [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm sorry but what
what do you guys prefer i'm going to
give you two options two i'm gonna give
you two cuban options okay
i'm gonna give you two cupid options you
could pick this
[Music]
nobody else
or or
we could play some real cubans and
you're drawing but now i know
but still hey i'm just pointing out the
music all right i put it
oh fine it's sad is it sadder than
[ __ ]
together erase all the mistakes
just like a guy he has
a good heart he also has dementia
did he [ __ ] or did he fart
no one knows what he's doing especially
joe
this isn't new but the
are in control
see c-a-g i didn't even say
she had to bleep it out for the clip
channel
you're welcome um i guess that ruined it
all right look
[ __ ] [ __ ] this guy is oh don't
worry
songwriter x we will be listening to
your music
you could have had a friend songwriter x
you could have had a friend
and instead this is what you did
you ruined it you just ruined it
uh i know i ruined it a.g i understand i
didn't do great